most of you who I've seen have got the
arm I've got the skeleton of the proof
thumbs up you've got the general idea
however this is exactly why I've done
second there is something pretty much
with the exceptional artisans pretty
much everyone is just kind of missed
just sort of it yeah just what I get an
answer the odds are looks like it makes
sense but there's some logic which you
just sort of just skipped over and we
want to I want to push on that a little
more okay so the first thing I'm going
to do is we're going to come back to
where we were before and I'm going to
ask us to say instead of the drew
they're being sorry original contra be
intended us I want to think about
observe my cheaters okay what happens if
I'm now considering side of us what
kinds of predictions can I make this
time okay so for instance what's similar
what can I just keep on the board that I
can you say yep that's fine and I'm
going to march on which ones are okay
first time thumbs up on this right
because sine inverse sine of us is an
increasing function all the way for
wherever it exists so that checks out
have its second one this is a bit of
problem is it because sine inverse the
whole point is the domain of san dimas
comes from the range of sign okay so
therefore it certainly doesn't exist for
all real values what would you like to
do to adjust it from negative 1 to 1
sounds a lot better yeah okay good how
about this next bit this is about the
evenness of the function we're not
expecting this to be an even function
are we and this is kind of a particular
thing that we notice that a bit even so
this whole point here is out rather get
rid of this can we say anything similar
we can't say about the extremities but
the sine inverse graph it kind of has
its own extremities what can you tell me
about those extreme what you doing about
the gradient what are you expecting it
to do
yeah it couldn't so when I'm gonna say
this two ways right when I'm approaching
what's the left-hand extremity what
values its negative one but I'm going to
be even more precise than that you can
only approach for one direction yeah boy
things ah you can't come from the left
because site if it doesn't exist over
there yeah you can only come from the
right so how would I write this I have a
little plus right I'm approaching from
love so the limit as X approaches thing
to want from from that direction that
should be the same as the limit when I'm
approaching the other side which is what
I 11 and I'm pushing it from the
negative sighs what am I approaching yes
yeah it's whatever the gradient of
vertical digit is because we're talking
in the limits land we can say you know
the ludus approaches positive in sydney
that's okay that's what I should be
getting to how about this last one also
works right that's kind of convenient
the graded they're also equal to one but
that's not that surprising because when
we're doing all those original things
about the relationship between sine X X
and tenants we were showing they all
behave in the same way and zeroed
remember that behavior at the origin
okay so I've done these are my
predictions have a role flinders ok
again don't be really cheap when I go
ahead and change my original function in
to sign Dobie save different sizes
only a little bit different I'm okay
with the boundaries but I include the
boundaries this time ok so here I'm now
saying well ok i'm interested inside of
us down but there something's different
right the derivative of sine is
something else going back to my original
function it's cos x x so therefore when
I say okay now I'm try to get to the
inverse right I'm trying to get at that
this is the reciprocal so I go whatever
cos x now I pause here the next thing I
wrote down was the Pythagorean identity
that made sense last time because I had
sex squared on the bottom but I don't
have cos squared here so I can't use the
Pythagorean identities directly right
let's have a look at this guy I can't
use you just have to be careful and this
is what most people have just kind of
our very Cavalier Way just conveniently
forgotten this is me rearranging okay I
don't want cos squared I just what
clothes yet you're tracking with me so
far so i'm going to write cos x equals
now maybe just point out all of us
everyone who i've looked at his point of
me out who's asked me to come over
another level has taken the square root
of both sides and just artfully ignored
the fact that if you're solving for x
squared equals a square right you're not
getting one solution for X you should be
getting too ok now why are there two
solutions yeah because you mean the wall
do because in a domain yep I'm 5525 too
ok good so you're actually you're my
step ahead of me right let me just come
back to why there are two solutions
right if you have a look at the concert
I need a little bit morning here's the
cost curve half of the cost curve is
underneath the axis you better believe
there's a possible ends there right so
depending on your domain you'll get one
for the other the question is which one
so you have to answer the question of
domain thankfully I did that in the
first slide of my proof right
between negative PI or two and pilot une
that's this portion of Cossacks right do
you see the portion that I've restricted
to and in that entire domain coz X is
greater than or equal to 0 right so i
can say what because of this domain and
you must invoke this you can't just say
cuz i want to be right because i predict
dip it in what to be right i can say in
this domain since since i have this
restriction right i can know about the
sign of context i'm ok with 0 because
the site doesn't go either way ok
therefore in this domain D X on dy is
equal to 1 over the positive square root
early ok that was the thing that um we
didn't have to deal with when we're
doing the tan inverse proof from here
just kind of proceeds just like it did
before I know what sine X is it's why
right so this is square root up so 1
over the square root r 1 minus y squared
now you can see why in the previous one
I wrote is 1 plus whatever because
that's that way you get the order the
same now I've got the X on d1 what I
really want is everything switched
around ok so therefore i can say if
rather than x equals tan inverse of Y if
I swap inputs and outputs sorry yeah I
think so we're ready to table if I do a
site in verse there for dy/dx equals ok
now what did we do at this stage in our
previous proof what did we do I Detroit
but before I got to my drawing I said
does this match what i was hoping to get
what do you think she'll go through one
of those high is it always positive yeah
because by definition you have a
squaring on the bottom so wherever that
exists it's
so positive that looks good how about
the domain restriction it looks good
doesn't it because here if x squared
gets a smaller than negative 1 or bigger
than anyone yeah now now figure out this
right we're a bit sneaky here we really
should have guessed from this point that
this is incorrect right this is true of
sine inverse but it's not true of the
gradient why not because there's a
vertical tangent we just we said that
the next topic so that looks good as
well too doesn't it have a look as X
gets closer and closer to one what
happens to the whole denominator when X
Kirsten closer to one the denominator is
going to get tiny so that's why the
whole thing gets it always okay and last
thing does it pass the test easy okay
now now let's draw okay and it's a
simple drawing again we're doing it I
don't need that much of the bottom with
the denominator is a very simple
function we should be familiar with this
guy what's the denominator what kind of
shape is it it's a semicircle isn't so
this is what it looks like that's the
denominator but when I actually take the
reciprocal what happens there's one easy
point to do then we at one its
reciprocal is itself and then when you
look at the rest of this you're in fact
getting these vertical asymptotes here
and off it goes like that okay does that
make sense which is very pleasing in
terms of its symmetry with arms or is
all we got for 10x10 adverse effects
which itself okay now i'm not going to
go ahead and prove the result because in
most remembering what we established
yesterday in terms of this result and we
looked at the grass how we fit together
you can now make a very curious as to
what you expect the derivative of cos
inverse to be what would you expect yeah
it's the same thing but negative right
the picture certainly looks like that
but I would like you to go ahead and
prove it because
a slight change in the logic because
it's a change in the domain okay once
you've got that haha you just unlocked a
whole new family of curves and a great
and functions which also means they're
integrals as well